[Musique]
salut c'est fait aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler d'un produit que j'ai reçues
et pas très longtemps
c'est un produit que j'ai envie de
tester depuis un petit moment cette
grosse machine je passe s'avoue pas
mieux vous parlez si je fais ça c'est le
surface pro de microsoft c'est vraiment
un format 2 en 1 320 mm on va rentrer
dans le détail on va regarder un petit
peu ce que ce microsoft surface pro a
dans le ventre
alors c'est pas un tout nouveau tout
nouveau produit on apparaît déjà dans
tout nouveau projet de microsoft n'a pas
longtemps et on va continuer en parlant
de reparlera à la rentrée celui là il
déjà sorti l année dernière néanmoins
c'est quand même une machine référente
aujourd'hui donc c'est important d'en
parler donc on va regarder ses fesses en
phase iii dans le ventre si l'intérêt
sens il faut l'acheter oui ou non si oui
dans quelle configuration
on va regarder les accessoires parce que
j'en ai pas mal on va se poser toutes
ces questions ça on le fait maintenant
surface pro à la base lorsque vous
l'acheter c'est ça c'est cette tablette
en formant un peu particulier quand même
un condo à avoir là-dessus on n'a pas un
format 13 pouces on n'a pas du tout un
format 15 pouces
on a un format 12 3 pouces avec une
résolution de 2 minutes 736 par 1824 à
267 ppp donc c'est vraiment une
résolution un petit peu bâtard on n'est
pas dans ses habitudes de retrouver
usuellement sur le marché néanmoins
reconnaître que ça fait franchement à
faire ça c'est une oeuvre d'art de mon
petit donc c'est pas moi je sais que des
signes très mal mais quand même là c'est
pas à moi pour le coup vous avez donc un
format qui est un petit peu bâtard mais
qu bon malgré tout et pas max de très
allongée donc c'est vrai que ça ces
pratiques alors le côté sympa de ce
produit c'est que vous pouvez l'utiliser
comme une tablette
naturellement comme ça en tendant la
main vous pouvez également l'ouvrir pour
ensuite venir le poser directement sur
un support ça c'est le fameux mode
tablette comme ça ou comme ça on sait
d'où arrivent au studio vous allez
l'ouvrir davantage vous allez poser
comme ça pour venir dessiner faire vos
créations
je pense surtout aux infographistes au
graphisme peut-être de la prise de notes
pas qu'après note c'est être un peu plus
rapide à la volée comme ça ou pour
bosser si vous aimez avoir une vue du
dessus lorsque vous bossez et ça peut
aussi être intéressant et le dernier mot
de passe utilisés avec cet accessoire là
c'est accessoire annoncé le clavier
surface protic covered que vous allez
directement mettre sur votre machine
c'est à dire qui va retrouver très très
très facilement sa place là parce que il
est monté à envoyer il trouve sa place
tout de suite vous allez le faire mais
ça vous fait un petit étui vous fermez
tout ce dont vous avez vraiment une
protection format étui et ça c'est
vraiment génial pour l'emmener partout
lorsque vous l'ouvrez séoul ouvre un peu
comme le bouquin vous avez un clavier et
à vous avez plusieurs possibilités soit
vous laisser pendre comme ça et vous le
posez devant ça vous fait un format un
peu ordinateur un peu à plat sinon il
vient cémenté directement là et ça nous
fait un clavier qui a une légère courbe
urs est intéressant également entre
accessoire indispensable c'est le stylet
vous le prenez vous peser y trouve sa
place
il vient c'est monté directement là
c'est plutôt bien fait dernier
accessoire et pas des moindres c est la
petite souris la petite souris qui est
très intéressante pour de vrai il faut
la halle a plié en deux c'est la souris
arc de microsoft retrouve bien
de par le format parce qu'elle vient
vraiment épouser la forme de votre main
et sa focus intéressant alors que ce
soit le clavier que vous avez ici ou là
sourit ce qu'on est tous les deux en
bluetooth c'est du bluetooth 4 points et
ça fonctionne extrêmement bien la
surface pro pouvez l'utiliser comme ça
soit directement en mode tablette vous
la posez là comme ça en mode studio vous
la basculer et là vous pouvez prendre
des notes écrire par tout ce que vous
voulez et c'est vrai que c'est super
intéressant lorsque vous êtes en mode
tablette vous avez un mode qui est quand
même à part on n'est plus dans une
interface un peu windows disent un peu
classique est là pour nous c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant vous avez tout
votre gestion ici vous avez toutes vos
applications que vous pouvez retrouver
là c'est vrai que c'est quand même
extrêmement pratique et là vous avez
tout à portée de main c'est vraiment
bien ensuite lorsque vous voulez passer
en mode studio hop vous n'avez qu'à
l'inquiéter comme ça vous prenez votre
stylet et de la même manière vous allez
pouvoir écrire dessiner faire ce que
vous voulez le directement dessus ça
c'est pratique ancienne config est pas
des moins de vouloir dresser vous
emmener directement le petit clavier ici
hop ça se connecte directement dessus
vous le mettez comme ça il vous propose
de quitter le mode tablette pour arriver
au mode ordinateur
ok on y va vous pouvez vraiment le
régler l'inclinaison comme vous le
souhaitez en fonction de votre confort
en fonction des besoins en fonction tout
ce qui vous arrange ça s'est vraiment
bien alors point positif c'est que le
clavier quand même extrêmement doute
format très compact
vous pouvez le laisser comme ça vous le
faire mais ça me protège vous pouvez
l'ouvrir avec windows est l'objet d'une
reconnaissance faciale je me mets en
face au ca me reconnais sa déverrouille
directement c'est vraiment hyper rapide
et hyper secure donc ça c'est super cool
la navigation est fluide la jeanne intel
core i7 donc forcément ça marche plutôt
bien je vais vous prendre un pin 3d par
exemple pour faire quelques dessins très
très basique improbable le
fonctionnement du stylet fonctionne
extrêmement bien vous avez différents
types alors bon on va pas rentrer là
dedans parce qu'après et c'est plus
destinée personnes qui ont envie de
faire du graphisme des choses comme ça
ce qu'il est globalement pas du tout mon
cas côté cool vous pouvez effacer ici
vraiment un néophyte un envoyé mai
vous avez vraiment un stylo sous la main
pour pouvoir dessiner sur toutes vos
skis sur tout ce que vous voulez et
sachons reconnaître que c'est vraiment
bien propres accessoires et pas des mois
c'est la petite souris que vous avez ici
je me positionne je clique je ferme je
n'enregistre pas parce que j'ai fait un
truc horrible je vais sur internet en
utilisant ça je peux naviguer tout
simplement ici et ça c'est plutôt bien
pour les activer économiser la batterie
vous n'avez pas de bouton on off vous
avez juste à la claque vous la remettez
comme ça elle part dans la poche dans le
sac et saint roch en place un accessoire
qui est vraiment cool pour la
portabilité vous le prenez vous le faire
mais vous partez vous faites ce que vous
voulez ça la désactiver dès que vous
l'affirmez ici parce que ça va
reconnaître qu'il est fermé pour poser
votre stylet dessus vous mettez votre
souris dans votre poche et expliqua
parti en voyage en charge aussi facile
vous avez ici votre bloc secteur votre
prise et ici l'adaptateur qui vient
directement se flinguer ici et comme
cémenté ça fonctionne tout seul il vient
trouver sa position très naturellement
c'est extrêmement simple en terme de
connectique vous avez de l'usb 3 mini
display port vous avez de ce côté là un
port jack les deux côtés sont aimantés
pour pouvoir venir faisait votre stylet
dessus alors bien évidemment le style et
vous allez le poser uniquement de ce
côté là lorsque vous n'avez pas à la
recharge sinon c'est pas du tout
possible et autre point qui est
intéressant lorsque vous aurez ici vous
voyez qu'une petite place pour
d'avenches et si une carte micro sd
lorsque vous voulez rajouter la mémoire
faire du stockage et de la sauvegarde
ont normalement en termes de stockage ne
voyez pas être embêté alors si vous avez
des problèmes de stockage de choix
précipité de rajouter cette carte micro
sd directement dedans vous aussi
brancher un disque dur externe via l'usb
ou alors ou alors vous prenez une
configuration hyper hot avec le ssd il
faut savoir vous avez plusieurs
configurations cette machine que ce soit
en terme de puissance en terme de ram de
processeurs de cartes graphiques mais
également des disques durs
vous avez trois types de processeurs à
l'intérieur le premier à une telle corps
m3 voulu pour avoir en 4 gigas de ram et
128 go de stockage
dans ce cas là la carte graphique ça
sera une intel hd graphics 615 bon si
vous avez du talent core i5 8 gigas de
ram soit 128 go de stockage ssd toujours
c'est que du ssd soit 256 go de stockage
lorsqu'elle avait 15 graphics une intel
hd graphics 620 et ensuite vous avez
elin tel core i7 ça c'est la machine que
je teste soit 8 gigas de ram et 256 go
de stockage soit 16 giga de ram 512 giga
de stockage ou alors carrément un
terrain bien évidemment c'est un terrain
en ssd et dans ce cas la carte graphique
sunnites et à l'iris plus 640
alors vous vous en douterez les tarifs
varient forcément d'une configuration à
l'autre sur la plus grosse configuration
les tarifs s'envolent à savoir en plus
que lorsque vous achetez votre surface
pro où vous n'avez ni stylet ni clavier
ni souris pour acheter les surfaces pro
avec les hôtels corps m3 4 gigas de ram
128 go de stockage
il vous en coûtera 949 euros sur intel
core i5 me giga de ram 128 giga de
stockage sabots coûtera 1149 euros sur
la version 256 giga de stockage nous en
coûtera 1449 euros
ensuite sur le i7 et c'est vraiment la
crêperie s'envole sur la config 8 gigas
de ram 256 go de stockage il vous en
coûtera 1799 euros
si vous voulez du 16 giga de ram 512
giga de stockage
c'est ce que j'ai moi ici 2499 euros est
alors carrément en 16 giga de ram et un
terrain de stockage en ssd 3099 euros
auxquels il faut rajouter 109 euros 99
de style et 149 99 de claviers et 89
euros 99 2 souris et d'autres
accessoires comme la station d'accueil
qui à 229 99 pas mal de possibilités
mais c'est vrai que ce soit un peu le
point négatif que j'ai vraiment cette
tablette parce que je la trouve super
intel core i7 16 giga de ram 512 giga de
stockage va pas se mentir c'est quand
même une bête de compagnie c'est une
bête de course la machine répond
extrêmement bien il
non aucune latence l'autonomie
excellentes ça dépend bien évidemment de
votre utilisation tournant autour des 10
11 ans d'autonomie a sans aucun problème
il ne bronche absolument pas mais qu'est
ce que je regrette un peu la danse c'est
la politique tarifaire c'est extrêmement
cher mais d'un autre côté on va pas
avoir un produit pas cher alors qu'on
est sur un produit trop effectivement on
pouvait rêver du côté de la concurrence
il ya de tout à tous les prix on met de
côté c'est pas hyper déconnante pour
avoir un intel core i7 16 giga de ram
512 ou un terrain ça se tient malgré
tout ça peut quand même être enfin parce
que si je fais l'addition la config que
j'ai ici sinon comme intel core i7 16
giga de ram 512 ya le stockage de 1499
auquel je vais rajouter mon clavier
149,99 auquel je rajoute mon style et
120 99 auquel je rajoute m'a souri 89,99
j'arrive à un tarif très coquet de 2008
148 euros avec 97 centimes c'est cher on
va pas se mentir
à côté de ça j'ai vraiment une bécane
qui est top
mais c'est cher alors au début je me
suis dit c'est qu'on sait qu'on
d'acheter ma surface pro d'un côté et de
ne pas avoir de style est pas votre
clavier la souris bon on peut encore
précisément soit passé mais ça me
paraissait nécessaire est quasiment
obligatoire aux produits d'avoir au
moins le stylet et le clavier et je me
suis dit pourquoi ne pas les vendre
ensemble sur un même package
j'ai réfléchi au final de ce qui s'est
passé comme ça c'est même plutôt très
intelligente et assez malin parce que on
n'oblige pas les gens à acheter un style
et s'ils ne veulent pas le stylet et on
n'oblige pas les gens à acheter deux
claviers s'ils ne veulent pas acheter de
clavier dans l'absolu on va protéger le
consommateur c'est vraiment une
proposition à tiroirs vous acheter le
produit de base c'était forcément la
surface pro et après vous mettez ce que
vous voulez entendre vos besoins de vos
envies de vos besoins qui peuvent
évoluer et que vous envie également donc
au final c'est plutôt intéressant
je me suis dit on au grand comme un
produit 2 en 1 donc si je vais en
produit 2 en 1 faut quand même que j'ai
les accessoires avec c'est à dire que si
j'achète ça tout seul et tout nu et j'ai
un produit un an
en réalité nos j'ai un produit 2 en 1
mais en réalité ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est ce n'est pas un produit deux
annoncé un produit trois ans parce que
je vous explique vous avez le mode
tablette vous pouvez tenir comme ça la
verticale comme vous voulez peut
l'ouvrir aussi pour faire tenir vous
avez le studio vous l'ouvrez vous prenez
vous le poser à plat pour bien bosser
dessus et vous avez le mode ordinateur
sauf que pour avoir le mode ordinateur
il faut utiliser le clavier qui vient se
connecter directement dedans
et là effectivement ça bouffe un
ordinateur mais si vous n'avez pas cet
accessoire là ce n'est plus un
ordinateur portable
c'est une tablette qui a effectivement
la possibilité d'avoir un mode studio
donc ça change un petit peu l'adn du
produit savoir qu'à l'avant vous avez
une caméra faciale de 5 mégapixels
permettra de faire des visioconférences
notamment par skype qui marque
aujourd'hui de microsoft et à l'arrière
vous avez également une autre caméra de
8 mégapixels
les deux vous permet de filmer en 1080p
autre point intéressant vous avez deux
haut parleurs à l'avant haut-parleurs
stéréo qui se situent en haut de chaque
côté de la machine sont haut-parleurs
dolby audio premium et je dois
reconnaître franchement que le som
marche très bien
si vous voulez regarder un film vous
regardez les vidéos youtube d'une
éthique ce que vous voulez vous avez du
son et franchement ça crache on rassure
centré sur cette page
regardez ce qu'est vraiment intéressante
par rapport à l'ipad 9,7 pouces de cette
année la question fatidique
à qui s'adressent ces surfaces pro la
première réponse doit être assez
évidente aux professionnels forcément
qui dit surface pro vie professionnelle
c'est dans le nom windows dix procès du
procès pour les pros sur la grosse
config avec al intel core i7 beaucoup du
stockage de la puissance accès ziga
drame s'adresse ou prou aux pros du
design aux personnes qui ont besoin de
griffonner de prendre des notes de
bosses et de faire de la réunion un vrai
outil à 360° conforme des partout avec
soi pas même continuer de bosser chez
soi jusqu'à 23h minuit 1h du mat si on
le souhaite
l'outil est assez intéressant sur des
grosse config quand on a des
possibilités de financer que ce soit sur
des parcs d'entreprises ou alors sur un
usage professionnel lorsqu'on est chef
d'entreprise ou alors lorsqu'on est
créatif qu'on est indépendant
ça peut vraiment avoir un sens ça peut
être vraiment un très bon outil
pourquoi pas peut-être en complément
d'un ordinateur un peu plus gros peut
imaginer une collection sur le cloud est
pas mal de possibilités d'autant plus
que vous pouvez le relier prêt à votre
smartphone que ce soit sur android ou
sur un os donc c'est plutôt intéressant
ça c'est de prendre des points qui
effectivement évident parce que c'est
dans le nom à mon sens ce produit se
destine pas aux étudiants pour les
étudiants en dira plus sur une surface
go pour un usage pro c'est plus ce
produit là à mon avis trop 10 destine
surtout aux personnes qui ont vraiment
des exigences qui veulent une machine
performante une machine adaptable qu'on
peut emmener partout avec qui on va
faire du traitement de texte bosser sur
des présentations ou on peut griffonné
prendre des notes dessinée ont envoyé
des idéaux et des croquis oui des
esquisses directement et partager à
titre professionnel puis même pourquoi
pas à titre familial on peut imaginer
complètement aux 17 machines là à titre
personnel au final le surface pro c'est
vraiment une machine complète qui
s'adresse à tout un chacun dès lors
qu'on a la possibilité de financement et
qu'on peut se payer machine comme
celle-là ça reste néanmoins un
ordinateur tablette exigeant et si vous
pouvez vous permettre vous ne le
regretterez pas voilà pour celle du la
surface pro de microsoft dit non plus
que vous en pensez est ce que c'est un
produit qui pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter est-ce que vous avez déjà un ipad
pro
produits qui peuvent vous paraît en tout
cas similaire est ce que vous avez des
produits de microsoft dans la gale
surface est ce que le surface pro vous
l'avez déjà vous l'avez déjà vu est ce
que le surface dont on peut vous faire
de l'oeil vous marque sans commentaire
mais évidemment on reste une fois de
plus connectés et vous allez voir un
d'ici quelques temps on va tester la
surface go comme ça je pourrais vous
dire également ce que j'en pense merci à
vous d'être toujours plus loin toujours
plus nombreux soyez sages portez vous
bien mes témoins toutes vos questions et
suggestions interrogations en bas en
commentaire et à très bientôt vous
embrasse tiens
[Musique]